hello everyone as it often is when a
metal table is a tournament there's
usually a fun story or two involved and
this tournament was no exception
this game was played in 1974 when
Michael towel was visiting Poland for
the first time but he didn't respond to
play a chess tournament it was actually
a family trip but style decided to play
the tournament anyway and this gaming
compound was playing with the white
pieces against a Polish international
master Yan Adamski and okay he wasn't an
international natural when this game was
played he got a side of two years after
this game but he was definitely a
stronger strong opponent you know you
couldn't really mess around with him so
let's say this game and the story that
goes with it
towel is white and he goes efore we have
c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6
we have v4c capture some d4 Knight after
some d4 and we have Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 g6 and tau goes for
the early g4 we have h6 buttinsky and
tile goes g5 we have H captures on g5
Bishop captures on g5 and Knight to c6
and ok subway is a Queen to d2 preparing
queenside castle and we have win d6
attacking that knight on d4 and it's all
retreats is Knight to b3 we have a 6
South Castle queenside and Bishop to be
seven a d7 sorry we have a Bishop to G 2
by tau and on ice the e5 quinta e to rip
the c8 and now F 4 and we have nicely
for
wrote the d3 and this route to d3 will
be a useful move later as it will
prevent black firm sacrificing the
exchange here on c3 which is well
usually the case 1 black plays the
Sicilian
we have Queen to c7 and top plays h4
Bishop to e7 and now rook to e1 and b5
and top way is the strongest move in the
position that he plays d5 we have D
captures on e5 and now F captures and e5
attacking that night and nice to h5 and
the top place is Queen to f2 and in this
position Tulsa
that young Adamski over him would draw
even before the game even started
even though Adamski was wasn't even an
international master and tall was
already well renowned the world champion
so in this position as well as on scale
$4 draw and thought said that this was
very annoying to him and he plays teenis
- whatever without even considering the
position too much and he blunders upon
here so Adamski of course captures its
mad captures on e5 and here well it's a
better position for black tal really
shouldn't have allowed this but he plays
rook to h3 with ideas of complicating
the position we have f6 by Adamski and
south plays Bishop to e3 and now b4 and
this before well this is a very
dangerous move as the knight doesn't
really have anywhere to go
the bishop is covering the a Foursquare
he doesn't really want to put it to be
one he can't put it to e2 because then
it's checkmate uncie - and if you play
something like Knight to e4 well then
simply Knight to b3 forking the kingdom
queen with check and white can't capture
than that because the pawn is pinned
from the Queen and c7 so after that b4
move by Adamski tau played Bishop to b6
and here we have nice - g4 and this
Knight to g4 is the strongest move
attacking the Queen and well again black
is much better here but style doesn't
play something like Queen g1 or simply
you know trying to play a worse position
towel of course tries to complicate
things and he plays nice to d5 and
already you can see it's quite quite a
mess in the position and how is actually
offering the space piece here for free
or although it doesn't seem to be for
free because they were both in I mean in
this position Adamski was in bigger time
trouble but this is actually what
Adamski probably saw and is the reason
why he rejected the night if eeek a
person d5 Bishop captures in c7 like has
to recapture the Queen so a night
captures an f2 and now Bishop to b6
pinning this Bishop on e7
we have nice captures on h3 and now rook
captures an e7 the King can go to f8
because the wall if you will lose too
much
cereal soaking 38 and now nice the a5
with ideas of checkmate on b7 but this
is defendable with a move like rook to
c4 for example making room for the king
and c8 although it does give up for
rooks for the exchange but black is
still better but a dance kit was so low
on time that he didn't want to
complicate things and he didn't want to
capture this night so Adamski simply
plays and Knight captures an f2 and the
top lane light captures on c7 would
check so ok
tal is down a pawn but this is playable
now so again the magician managed to
trick his opponent we have a rook
captures on c7 and now rook to f3
getting the rock out of harm's way
rook to c8 and this is a very important
position as well because it was in this
position or maybe a move before this
position that Adamski stopped riding the
moves but stall convenient although none
of them were really paying attention to
this course this is a note sheet as well
they were both in time trouble but the
important thing is that house wife
Angelina Petukhov or Angelina towel at
the time
continues to count Adamski's moves as
she was also a chess player herself we
have rook captures an f2 e v Bishop to
e3 nice to g3 Bishop Bishop to b7 rope
to c7 and our towel while captures upon
an a6 but after this Knight to f5 move
attacking the bishop on e3 and Bishop to
e2 Adamski grabs another pawn on h4 and
again tile is down upon so we have a
Bishop to d3 we have g6 King Bishop to
e3
King to a7 Bishop to b6
rook to b7 nice to c5 attacking the rook
and the bishop so recapture some b6 and
nice capture Sun d7 rook the d6 now
attacking this night we have a knight to
c5 rook to c6 again attacking the night
at our place
nice back to thee 7 as this is move 38
and the both players are low on time so
tal repeats the position a couple of
times just to reach move 40 and the
reach time control we have rook to c7
and
nice to be six this is move 39 his
opponent now plays Bishop to c5 and it
seems tall blundered a piece here
because this Bishop attacks both nice
and b6 and rook on f2 and here tau plays
Bishop to c4 and this is move 40 so tau
plays move 40 and plays Bishop to c4
which chick but he immediately realizes
that this is losing the game as the
simple route capture some c4 Knight
captures and c4 loses the stroke on f2
so after Col made this Bishop to c4 move
he said okay I resigned the game and as
he was going to congratulate his
opponent his wife intervened and she
said no don't resign your opponent miss
radensky lost on time and really his
flag did fall and and the the official
arbiter awarded stall a victory in this
game and it was a big fuss mister mister
Adamski was really mad and he didn't
like that style wife got involved and he
said that well it doesn't matter if my
time fell I mean that I was some time if
it's all resigned the game without him
seeing that my time ran out and he even
filed an appeal to the official feed a
committee which consisted of five
members I don't really remember all the
members I know one member was a matter
damiana which of us la vía and well they
all agreed that the arbiter was correct
and that style should be awarded the
game and it was interesting miss
radensky stops writing the moves moved
25 and then at one point he asked
Sal if he could rewrite the moves from
Taos scorched front out sheet and then
he added two more moves so it would
appear as if he reached time control and
played more than forty moves so by the
definition that he couldn't lose in time
but star wife was counting the moves as
he played them and she said no he made
thirty nine moves and this was correct
so yeah
house wife actually won this game and
it's interesting that 38 years after
this game was played a news
Porter asked Yan Adamski about this game
and well he did say a couple of things
about one of the nicer things he said is
this was the best chance I ever had of
defeating a world champion and I even
managed to defeat him in a chess game
but against his wife I was helpless so
yeah a very nice story and it's
interesting mr. Oransky is still alive
his 73 years old and still an
international master and it would be
really interesting to hear mr. Adamski's
thoughts on this game now in 20 in 200
2017 so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and the story that went
with it and thank you all for watching
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and I will see you
soon oh yeah
before I forget how did you enjoy a game
of Thrones episode six and what do you
expect from episode seven so yeah thank
you for watching and I'll see you soon